INTRO:
With the rise of affordable streaming services
like Netflix, Disney+, and Hulu, we’ve seen
a significant reduction in piracy over the
past several years.
But, for those that still engage in piracy,
there’s no doubt that torrenting is the
key that makes it all possible.
If you’re not familiar with torrenting,
it’s basically a file distribution system
that makes it extremely difficult to shut
down piracy.
Instead of downloading a file from a central
server, with torrents, you download the file
from thousands of other people who have already
downloaded the file themselves.
So, piracy sites like The Pirate Bay and KickassTorrents
don’t actually have to host the files themselves.
They just have to host the torrenting links
that connect pirates from around the world.
So, if prosecutors takedown a certain piracy
website, the hosts of the website just have
to upload the links to a new website which
is no more than a few gigabytes.
In other words, they don’t have to move
the exabytes of data associated with the links
themselves.
This ease of moving websites has made it impossible
to shut down large websites like The Pirate
Bay, as they can just constantly move websites
thanks to torrents.
As you would guess, prosecutors and copyright
holders aren’t exactly big fans of the man
who invented torrents: Bram Cohen, but at
the same time, they can’t do anything about
it.
So, here’s the story of Bram Cohen and how
he accidentally invented the soul of piracy.
BRAM COHEN:
Taking a look back, Bram was born on October
12, 1975, in Manhattan, New York.
His father was a computer scientist and his
mother was a school teacher, so it looks like
the family didn’t have too much trouble
financially.
From a very early age, it was clear that Bram
wasn’t like most kids.
He had rather mature interests and excelled
at STEM-related competitions.
For example, when he was just 5 years old,
he was trying to learn the programming language
BASIC.
And let’s not forget, when Bram was 5, it
was 1980.
Even today, a 5-year-old learning computer
science would be quite impressive, but given
how much exposure children have to technology
today, it would make a lot more sense.
Back in 1980, the average person didn’t
even know why they needed a computer in the
first place.
Aside from an interest in programming, Bram
participated in several competitions such
as the USA Math Olympiad.
Despite this inclination towards academics,
it doesn’t seem like Bram was that sold
on the idea of school.
He didn’t stack on degree after degree like
many other geniuses.
Instead, he attended the University of Buffalo,
and as soon as he started getting job offers,
he left and never looked back.
Bram’s career throughout the 1990s wasn’t
that stable though.
It’s not clear if Bram couldn’t qualify
for a job at a big tech company like Microsoft
or Cisco or if he was trying to hit it big
with a startup, but either way, this forced
him to constantly switch jobs as each startup
he worked for went under.
While the startup world wasn’t too kind
to Bram, it did provide him with unique concepts
and ideas, and this was especially true with
his last job at MojoNation.
MojoNation was trying to create a decentralized
method for safely storing and distributing
confidential files.
The idea was that encrypted chunks of the
original file could be spread across multiple
computers.
This way, to download the entire file, you
would need cooperation from all of the computers.
So, a hacker couldn’t just get access to
one of these computers and steal the entire
file.
It’s not clear if this decentralized encryption
method ever caught on, but this idea did inspire
Bram who thought that it was perfect for file
sharing.
BITTORRENT:
In April of 2001, Bram went ahead and quit
MojoNation determined to bring his file-sharing
idea to life.
Over the next year, he programmed the first
BitTorrent client which ran on Python.
Soon enough, Bram completed a beta version
of the software that worked alright, but Bram
was well aware that the key to success was
not the program itself but getting people
to see it.
So, he worked with his roommate, Len Sassaman,
to create a tech conference that you might’ve
heard of: CodeCon.
Since then, even people as notable as Sergey
Brin and Elon Musk have presented at CodeCon.
But Bram and BitTorrent were the stars of
the first CodeCon.
This presentation allowed Bram to create some
hype within the tech world, but this was not
exactly his target audience per se.
So, Bram developed a new idea to attract users.
In the summer of 2002, Bram went out and got
some adult films and offered them for free
on BitTorrent.
This strategy was surprisingly effective,
but Bram didn’t want to be known as an adult
film distributor.
So after he built up a solid base of users,
he stopped seeding these films.
By this point though, many BitTorrent users
started to realize the true potential of the
program.
Nowadays we have extremely reliable cloud
storage platforms like Google Drive and Mega
which allow users to download gigabytes worth
of files in a matter of minutes.
But, back in the early 2000s, moving around
such large files was not only difficult but
expensive due to the storage and bandwidth
requirements.
So, no one wanted to host such files.
With BitTorrent though, no single person had
to host the files.
Instead, hundreds or even thousands of users
could host them.
And given that average people aren’t charged
for their bandwidth usage, this was basically
free for most hosts.
Considering these perks, I don’t think you’d
be surprised to hear that BitTorrent became
the go-to place to share and download large
files.
And naturally, it’s not like people needed
BitTorrent to share 4 GB word documents or
excel spreadsheets.
No, the most common files that were large
enough to require BitTorrent were movies,
games, and software.
And as users started to realize how easily
such files could be shared using BitTorrent,
the program quickly became the sole of piracy.
STANCE ON PIRACY:
Given BitTorrent’s major role within piracy,
it’s not surprising that BitTorrent was
a massive target for prosecutors.
But the problem is that they couldn’t really
charge BitTorrent or Bram of copyright infringement.
Bram has made it clear that he didn’t create
BitTorrent for piracy.
His main goal was simply to allow users to
share and download large files cheaper, faster,
and more efficiently than ever before.
And it just so happens that the community
started using it for illicit activities.
So, given that there was no conspiracy to
commit copyright infringement, prosecutors
can’t do anything.
It would be like the FBI taking action against
Facebook because scammers are using WhatsApp
to conduct Bitcoin scams.
With that being said though, piracy is a way
bigger part of BitTorrent than Bitcoin scams
are of WhatsApp.
So, prosecutors were constantly looking for
ways to build a case against BitTorrent.
But, Bram was well aware of this and he was
sure to play it safe legally.
He didn’t pirate himself, he didn’t encourage
others to pirate, and he constantly tried
to make BitTorrent more applicable to other
use cases as well.
So, this was Bram’s legal stance on the
piracy issue.
His moral stance, however, is a lot different.
Bram believes that copyright holders need
to get a life a stop going after every medium
that inadvertently enables piracy.
He argues that if copyrighted content was
offered in an affordable and easily accessible
way, people would have no reason to pirate
content.
And this does make sense given what happened
to the music industry.
Back in the 2000s, it was extremely common
to pirate music to put on MP3 players and
iPods.
But, with the explosive growth of services
like YouTube, Spotify, and Apple Music, music
piracy has significantly declined.
I mean, why would you want to go onto sketchy
websites and risk getting a virus when you
can legally listen to any song on YouTube
or Spotify for free with ads or for a reasonable
fee without ads.
So, I do think Bram’s argument makes quite
a bit of sense, but this didn’t stop copyright
holders from trying to fight back anyway.
RETALIATION:
Since copyright holders couldn’t directly
shut down or convict BitTorrent, they decided
to go after the ones that were sharing the
content themselves.
Initially, BitTorrent was slightly involved
in this given that there were links to copyrighted
material on BitTorrent’s official website.
But, in 2005, Bram made a deal with 7 American
studios that he would remove all piracy-related
links from the website.
This led to the rise of sites like The Pirate
Bay and KickassTorrents.
I have videos about both these sites if you’re
interested, but in this video, we’ll be
focusing on seeders.
Seeders are basically the thousands of hosts
around the world that are making the content
available to pirate.
And since copyright holders couldn’t take
down BitTorrent, they decided to take down
seeders.
Copyright holders started finding the IP addresses
of seeders and contacting their internet service
providers to cut their internet.
Considering these consequences, you might
be wondering, why would anybody seed content?
Well, within the piracy community, it’s
common courtesy to seed for as long as you
downloaded.
But, even if you don’t seed out of free
will, you’ll automatically be seeding as
you’re downloading the content itself.
For example, if you’re pirating Avengers
End Game and your progress bar is at 80%,
this means that you’ve already downloaded
the first 80% which you could be seeding as
you’re downloading the last 20%.
Copyright holders have actually gotten really
good at identifying seeders and cutting their
internet which has forced most pirates to
start using VPNs which is quite ironic.
If you’re pirating any amount of substantial
content, you’re gonna have to get a paid
VPN.
ExpressVPN’s cheapest option itself costs
$100 per year.
Meanwhile, Disney+ only costs $80 per year.
So, clearly, there’s some sort of disparity
going on here if pirates are more willing
to pay for a VPN than a streaming service
as Bram suggested.
Nonetheless, copyright holders have continued
to spend a lot of effort in taking down seeders.
LIFE AFTER BITTORRENT:
For many founders within the piracy community,
they have no life after founding the piracy
website.
Most of them have several charges against
them, they owe millions to copyright holders,
and/or they’re fugitives on the run.
But, given that Bram was always able to stay
on the legal side of the law, there’s nothing
restricting him, and he used this freedom
to move past BitTorrent.
In 2017, Bram founded a cryptocurrency company
called Chia Network.
One of the main goals of the company was to
move cryptocurrency away from proof of work
and onto proof of stake.
If you’re not sure what that means, it basically
means eliminating the need for miners.
Chia launched their coin in May of 2021, and
it hasn’t been doing so hot.
In fact, it’s down 95% from its peak.
But it should be noted that the coin launched
at the peak of the altcoin bull market, so
overall crypto conditions haven’t been too
kind to Chia.
With that being said though, given the existence
of much more popular projects with similar
goals like Solana and Cardano, it’s not
clear if Chia will ever take off.
I don’t think Bram minds too much though
given that he’s estimated to be worth $15
million.
At the end of the day, Bram was the mastermind
behind the file-sharing protocol that has
made piracy what it is today.
Despite this status within the piracy community,
prosecutors can’t really do anything to
Bram given that he didn’t create BitTorrent
with the intention of pirating nor does he
encourage or promote piracy.
This has allowed him to live a rather free
life relative to other piracy kings, but none
of his other projects thus far have achieved
similar levels of success to BitTorrent.
And that’s the story of the torrenting king
that the FBI can’t do anything about.
Have you ever used BitTorrent?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re thankful for
torrenting for legal purposes of course.
And, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.